you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
crisis talks in the energy sector after
low winds and rising gas costs cause
some providers to collapse
boris johnson tells the world's richest
countries to invest a hundred billion
dollars a year on climate action
and california is given a red flag
warning for increased fire danger
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and we challenge those who are coming up
with the solutions
now the uk's energy sector is in crisis
today a shortage of natural gas and wind
power is driving up energy costs and has
led to some of the smaller energy
providers completely collapsing and
therefore automatically moving their
customers onto the bigger companies but
says the business secretary the lights
will not go out this winter explaining
that the energy price cap will remain in
place so let's take a look at what the
current energy mix is supplying britain
today our data dashboard shows us that
right now it's 53 of our electricity is
coming from fossil fuels 32
is renewables and 15 is coming from
nuclear we can also show you why we've
got this here the global temperature
rise which is ticking up all the time
and the approximate time until we hit
that all-important one and a half
degrees there you can see just over 11
years that is is that number that is
feeding into the talks that are being
held in new york today and tomorrow in a
few moments we'll be live with our
political editor beth rigby who has
traveled with the prime minister but
let's just take a look at how we got to
this crisis in the energy sector well
firstly cold winters in europe and asia
put increased demand on gas supplies and
following the easing of coveted measures
in the summer in the uk a number of gas
and nuclear plants were down for routine
maintenance work that was put off during
the covert 19 pandemic well in europe
extreme heat waves and low winds meant
that the amount of electricity generated
through wind turbines fell dramatically
and the price of gas increased across
the continent and here the national grid
were forced to fire up one of the uk's
last remaining coal power plants for the
first time since march as an additional
source of energy that was because again
of that lack of wind
and then last week as if it couldn't get
any worse a fire broke out at a site in
kent at a key cross channel
interconnector between the uk and france
and that is now going to be shut off for
at least six months from now so what
effect will all of this have on energy
policy and the future of supply well
sky's business correspondent paul kelso
has more now from a wind farm in
alveston in gloucestershire
the global spike in gas prices has
exposed some flaws in the uk's energy
market and particularly in the smaller
challenger brands that came into the
market offering simple customer friendly
ways of buying energy at very low prices
now that was fine when they could buy
gas more cheaply than they were
promising to offer it to customers but
as prices rose
particularly above the price cap imposed
by the regulator off gem they find
themselves unable to provide energy
anything other than a loss and that is
going to make many companies there are
predictions go to the wall
this winter of course the long-term aim
is for the market not to rely on fossil
fuels not to rely on gas to produce
electricity which is currently the case
because of a number of pressures on the
uk generation market but it's to move to
renewables like this small wind farm in
gloucestershire it provides energy for
about 4 000 homes and what's good for
the uk's energy resilience is also good
for the planet it's economically and
environmentally sustainable to produce
your own energy from this kind of
facility problem is for now the uk is
not 100 self-sufficient when the wind
doesn't blow and the sun doesn't shine
fossil fuels are the fallback and as
long as that is the case consumers are
going to be vulnerable to global market
trends in those fossil fuels
well as we were hearing from paul there
that lack of wind was just one of the
contributing factors fueling the energy
crisis so what is going on well here is
our economics and data editor ed conway
to explain
why is it that the uk is facing what
some would call a supply crisis
certainly with energy prices being
really high the short answer is i'm
afraid there is no single short answer
but what we can do is look at some of
the data some of that data is really
striking this shows you gas prices so
it's wholesale gas prices that your
supplier might
pay and look for most of the past few
years because we're going back a few
years here back to 2016 they've been
around that kind of range in the last
few months just look at what's happened
wow it's gone up so fast actually the
biggest increase we have really ever
seen up to 178 pounds per them in short
it's the highest it's been and as a
result of that we're seeing electricity
prices uh rising very sharply as well
this is electricity price obviously
you've got different forms of generation
as we'll see uh in a moment some people
have been asking is it just the uk
facing this or are other countries in
europe facing similar problems as well
we'll look at this you can see we've got
a few other european countries and you
can see those lines
are going up they've gone up an awful
lot but they're not quite as high as
that black line which is the uk why is
it that the uk in particular is facing
high prices well it's a range of
different factors one of them is because
of the kinds of uh sources we rely on
for our power so this is just showing
you where we get our electricity from uh
in the uk you can see there's wind power
there are kind of fossil fuels so coal
and gas power that used to be a lot is
less now than it was wind powers going
up and up uh but then you've got other
for instance nuclear and the striking
thing to note here is look at wind it
was going up and up and up but just in
this last autumn what we're looking at
is each autumn of each year basically in
the latest autumn it's gone down a fair
bit so we've had less wind power coming
in and as a result of that you know
that's part of the reason why prices are
slightly higher like i say it's not
everything there's all sorts of factors
going on at the same time which are
pushing up gas prices around europe but
that's one of the uh issues in the uk
and look when you look at what's
happened to wind speeds in the uk over
the past 20 years that's your historic
range through the year look at what's
happened in 2021 they've really been
quite low and that's just going up to
july we're expecting quite low numbers
for august and september as well so low
wind some issues with high gas prices
it's all added up to what a lot of
people are calling the supply crisis
well it is just 42 days until that big
climate summit cop26 that's being held
in glasgow but today prime minister
boris johnson is in new york he's at the
un general assembly where he's told
developed nations that for the fight
against climate change to be a success
countries need to find a hundred billion
dollars a year
i think that glasgow a cop 26 is a
turning point for
the world and it's it's the moment when
we have to to grow up and take our
responsibilities i think we go through
uh you know a period of of of glorious
uh indifference about the world we've
been through that we've been through our
childhood if you like we now got to
realize that
this is a this is a problem that
requires uh
grip
well let's bring in our political editor
beth rigby now who is in new york
evening to you beth how are those talks
going
well sam this really is a staging post
as one uh government official put it to
me on the journey towards cop and the
prime minister really laying it on thick
uh this morning as he pushes the g20
industrializations to be ambitious on
carbon uh and climate targets and also
pushing for that money he held a round
table with some of those nations that
are have faced an existential threat
from global warming that could in his
world slip below the work waves if sea
levels keep rising and according to
sources in that room let me just give
you a flavor of that discussion p.m
motley of barbados described hurricanes
as the heart attacks of the climate
crisis and called it the reckoning of
our lifetime as she called on developed
g20 nations to do
far more and then this from president
cassada of costa rica she said he said
if countries were private entities all
leaders would be fired as we're not
on track
and called in particular for biden to
put in more money into that 100 billion
dollar pot that you were talking about
it looks like they're about 80 billion
dollars there but some good news for
boris johnson this morning i managed to
catch up with president biden's special
envoy climate envoy
john kerry and i asked him about how
hopeful he was of hitting that target a
hundred billion by cop the prime
minister said six out of ten last night
here's what john kerry had to say
do you think president prime minister
johnson is doing a good job on climate
change
yeah i think he's doing a lot britain's
doing a lot they're prepping the meeting
and
fully determined to get it done so
i think we're all moving forward how
confident are you about hitting that 100
billion
dollar fund for developing nations well
i think we're going to get it done by
call yeah i think we're going to get it
done by cop sure
thank you beth
well stay with us because we're going to
be discussing that story and the ongoing
energy crisis shortly and today i'm
joined by the founder and chief
executive of climate policy radar
mikhail nakhmani and the climate
scientist michael e mann that is coming
up for you in just a few moments time
meanwhile in some of the day's other
climate news insulate britain has staged
protests on the m25 for the fourth time
a statement from the group said that the
actions will continue until the
government makes a meaningful commitment
to insulate all of britain's 29 million
leaky homes by 2030.
now you might recall the climate
campaigner dubbed the human swan we
featured her on the daily climate show
just a few weeks ago while she has been
seriously injured and a member of her
support staff killed in a paramotor
accident sasha dench was attempting a 3
000 mile journey in a motorized
paraglider to raise awareness of global
warming ahead of cop 26.
now parts of northern california have
been issued with a red flag warning that
is as wild fires continue to threaten
the local environment warm weather low
humidity and stronger winds are
increasing the risk of fire danger in
the state the knp complex fire in
sequoia national park formed after two
fires that were started by lightning
strikes merged just over a week ago
while that fire has now reached the
giant forest a grove of sequoias which
is home to the world's largest tree over
100 firefighters are battling to keep
flames away from the tree known as
general sherman it's over 2 000 years
old and 84 metres high giant sequoias
are adapted to fire which can help
release seeds from their cones and
create clearings that allow saplings to
grow but
large and intense fires like these can
overwhelm and damage those trees
well do stay with us because coming up
after the break we're going to be
talking about those climate discussions
ongoing at the un general assembly today
and we're going to look at possible
solutions
for the energy crisis here in the uk i'm
going to be joined by the founder and
chief executive of climate policy radar
mikhail nakhmani and the climate
scientist michael e mann
we know that we can't be complacent
about it uh it's caused increased
hospitalizations and deaths compared to
the previous variants
so the importance of vaccination as one
of the tools in which to combat it
is really important
and you can see that now the vaccines
being rolled out to further age groups
12 to 15 year olds and those over 50 and
those in high risk professions and with
underlying health conditions are going
to be offered a booster
so the delta variant is something that
we are concerned about as we head to
winter
82 percent uh of those been offered the
vaccine my understanding have had it
clearly there are a number who can't
have the vaccine for medical reasons um
and very young children are not being
offered the vaccine at the moment um a
high very high proportion of the
population have accepted the vaccine at
least one dose and most two doses
whilst we overall globally we have about
42 of the populations had one vaccine
in the lowest income countries such as
africa that's about two percent of the
population
and you know the mantra that who have
been saying which is so true that no
one's safe until everyone's safe
needs to be at the back of our mind
we cannot have vaccines that are being
wasted
vaccines that are expiring and just then
get thrown away so we have to look at
firstly
how we can ensure that vaccines that are
due to reach an expiry date could
possibly be shipped out and used
and also
for those countries that have
overstocked
which was an understandable action at
the beginning but now know based on the
calculations that they have got spare
vaccines we need to really make sure
that those vaccines are going to reach
those countries that are
desperately in need of it
i mean clearly going into this winter
the government have already set out
their plans plan a and plan b
vaccination is a very key component
of those plans but it's not the only
component so we've still got to be
mindful of the importance of
keeping ourselves safe through the basic
things like hand sanitization
ventilation because we're going to be
indoors more
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself
which houses frogs snakes crabs turtles
birds so many different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
welcome back to the daily climate show
on sky news we're getting straight to
discussing the climate issues of the day
that's with the founder and chief
executive of climate policy radar
mikhail nachmany and distinguished
professor of atmospheric science at penn
state university michael mann good to
see you both this evening well as we've
been hearing world leaders are gathering
in new york climate action very much at
the top of their agenda but are these
meetings coming too little
too late well i want to bring back in
here our data dashboard in particular
looking here at this this is 11 years
and four months that takes us to january
2033
before we hit that one and a half degree
target so with that in mind i really
like to start by asking uh by asking you
mikhail 2050 it's too late isn't it
2050 is way too late everything that
ticks on that board
is another fraction of a degree um is
another centimeter of rising sea levels
is another flood is another hurricane
there's more lives and livelihoods lost
if we were to end slavery would we say
let's end it in 30 years no this is
about cutting everything right now as
quickly as possible
and michael the un says that even if
countries stick to the pledges that they
have made temperatures will rise by 2.7
degrees by the end of the century what
does a world look like with temperatures
but higher by 2.7 degrees
well we don't want to find out that's a
world where you know you can imagine the
hottest day you've ever
experienced in your life and and that
may be a typical summer day if we can
you know continue down this path
and you know the most extreme weather
events the devastating weather events
that we're now seeing play out the super
storms the wildfires they'll become that
more
frequent they'll become that more
devastating so we don't want to find out
and that's why it's so important that
you know we not kick the can down you
know the road several decades as mccall
said we need to make sure that we
decarbonize our economy now
yeah and mikhail uh no
major emitters um
have a climate pledge that keeps them to
that one and a half degree target some
are close but the us for example is a
long way off
so we have two problems we have a
commitment gap so the promises that we
made are not good enough to get us to
where we need to but then also we have
an implementation gap even those that
make those commitments aren't taking us
uh far enough down the road and that is
true for uh uh all industrialized
nations and that is a a huge problem
that we need to tackle right away
some of the leadership that the uk has
to show now as the call president is
riling up those commitments but also
making sure that governments around the
world are living up to their commitments
sorry to interrupt you there michael the
other big gap michael is of course the
finance pledges 100 billion dollars a
year that was agreed more than a decade
ago in copenhagen by today's money that
would be 127 billion there is 100
billion even ambitious enough
well maybe not but it's a foot in the
door and there's no question we have to
provide incentives to developing
countries to india to some of the south
american countries africa
we can't afford for them to make the
same mistake that we in the industrial
world made we can't afford for them to
industrialize their economy by uh you
know by burning fossil fuels and so we
have to provide incentives that make it
an easy decision for them to leapfrog
past the fossil fuel stage embrace
renewable energy build clean energy
infrastructure to develop their
economies yeah but i mean the us isn't
isn't doing their part of the bargain
here though are they a recent estimate
suggests that the united states is only
providing four percent of its fair share
of that finance a long way to go
yeah well make no mistake uh about it uh
look we've seen some great pledges from
the current administration there are
certain
actions that the administration can take
executive actions but uh congress does
control the persp
string so ultimately we are going to
need congressional support that codifies
these commitments and as we speak we're
still
contending with this infrastructure
package and in particular reconciliation
package in congress where all of the
climate action really lies and we don't
yet have the votes to pass that even
with democratic control of congress and
so there's a lot of work to be done here
but the administration alone can't do it
we do need legislation that will codify
these efforts yeah so biden's going to
have to really be reaching across the
aisle isn't he on that well as i was
telling you earlier and you'll have
heard it on the news all day in the uk
gas prices have spiked there are
warnings of an energy crunch coming this
winter and it is not just here across
europe energy prices are rising fast and
in the united states this year there
have been blackouts in texas and
difficulties with the power grid in
california as well so how do we go about
solving this energy crisis and still
stick to the climate agenda and mikhail
coming to you first we were showing our
data dashboard earlier looking at the
power mix that we use to generate our
electricity still heavily reliant on
fossil fuels but particularly gas how do
we wean a country off its reliance on
gas
you're asking the the most important
question how do we wean ourselves off
fossil fuels and the answer is we do it
boldly and fiercely and urgently we do
it by starting to invest immediately not
only in um
first of all uh insulating homes uh
something that uh
often ties poor housing and uh and fuel
poverty and
increases the impact on those who are
already suffering the most
um
that would have resulted in a
significantly lower uh gas
bills for all of those
in the in the uk that now have to pay
the higher price secondly we need to
build infrastructure we need to invest
in research and development we need to
invest in deployment all of these things
are good things for the economy they
provide jobs they provide local jobs
they reduce dependence on uh on imports
they reduce dependence on fossil fuels
that need storage they reduce all of
those things that um we really need to
get uh off
and michael john kerry has said that 50
of the technologies that we need to do
this don't exist yet
where should we be putting our
attentions is it storage is it something
else
yeah i took issue with him when he said
that um i think he misspoke what he
meant was in 2050 several decades down
the road when we do have new
technologies we can't even envision yet
they will be contributing to
decarbonization in the middle of the
century as we go towards zero but in the
meantime we have the technology
renewable energy technology to
decarbonize our economy now to reach 50
percent reduction in carbon emissions by
the end of the decade which is what we
have to do writ large and it's what the
the dividend administration has pledged
to do but as mccall said this is about
infrastructure it's about making sure
that we have smart grid technology so
that when the wind isn't blowing or the
sun isn't shining we have energy storage
pumped hydro battery technology all of
these things are going to come together
and they're going to be essential along
with as mcculloch and said
energy efficiency we can make quite a
bit of progress simply by being more
efficient with the energy that we do
produce but the rest of the way it's
going to be
i'm sorry to cut you off there but we're
out of time michael eman mikhail mcmoney
really good to have you on the program
this evening thank you that is
everything from us for today joining
anna on the show tomorrow to discuss all
of the big issues will be the travel
writer juliette kinsman and george
monbio from the guardian hope to see you
tomorrow evening
[Music]
you